when is the last time you actually wrote
something down well if you're like me
you write a lot less than you used to
these days it's text messages emails
your phone
voice messages zoom
not everyone though here's a group of
women in the valley trying to preserve
the art of writing
so i'm going to write your name with one
blank sheet of paper
nancy sampson opens an entire world it's
the tools and the practice that make it
beautiful
it's a world of history and art nimble
hands and steady patience i can write a
hand that they used in the 400s the
practice of calligraphy calligraphy is
not quick she picked it up almost 40
years ago now as most of the world texts
and emails its way through the day
samson works on this craft it's an
expression and she's not the only one
this is
faux calligraphy and i love it these are
the fabulous las vegas scribes a club
for calligraphy when things are
neat and tidy and colorful and balanced
i get great joy from it they meet every
few months honing their handwriting
last weekend they gathered in person for
the first time since the pandemic
started yeah i like that working and
collaborating on all sorts of art yeah
yeah yeah that's really nice i started
doing calligraphy
30 years ago and so
it becomes just some writing on an
envelope and you just want to do more
it's not that they don't appreciate how
we communicate these days after all we
set this story up through email not with
courier pigeons it's beautiful handmade
artwork but the scribes feel like that
skill of handwriting and that art of
calligraphy it's slowly getting lost
this is an expression this is creative
this is a flourish i think history is
important we don't want to lose our
history with each stroke the scribes
hope to save it it is a fading skill and
it shouldn't be
the good day las vegas symphony
orchestra so here are the bookmarks that
they gave me here as you can see they
wrote my name here oh my gosh and
there's the scribes which i thought was
kind of cool heather this is for you
that is just bookmark beautiful now i
forgot to get ones for for sherry and
nate we were just trying to think of
things to say so here's wolfgang will be
nate wolfgang we're looking for random
names and nancy will be sherry
okay she's now in golden knights oh my
gosh
so much talent yeah and actually this
will come in handy yeah for for your
reading and this is all this is what
they've done for the story it's very
cool so thanks to the fabulous las vegas
scribes yeah what a great thing to learn
and preserve and hopefully more people
will maybe watch this and pick it up
yeah it's fun time they have a they're
very active on facebook it's very funny